when lori cash of new york took a job
with the u.s postal service
22 years ago it was for the security of
a government job
and a chance to work closely with the
public
to be able to service the public and do
something that i know
is helping people every day has just
always been appealing to me
but lately she's been hearing more
complaints from customers
dealing with delayed mail we'll have
someone mail a package in one city
and it takes three or four or five days
to get to the next city over
only 38 percent of first-class mail was
delivered on time
in late december according to postal
service court filings
that means everything from medications
to bill payments arriving late
and it's a problem that persists people
have got their bills delayed
when they've sent them to uh to
companies or utilities
companies or utilities or then charging
late fees
small businesses that once depended on
the u.s postal service to ship
products are also suffering maryland
boutique owner farzan jaeger
says many of the gift orders she
received before christmas
weren't delivered in time even pass way
past the holidays we would get emails
where is my gift did it receive did it
get delivered to the recipient
she now uses private shipping carriers
though they're more expensive
the u.s postal service lost more than 9
billion dollars in business in 2020
though the delivery delays that drove
away some customers
will likely improve after covid the
agency's long-running money troubles
will be harder to tackle
because its costs routinely exceed its
revenues
the man tasked with finding a solution
is postmaster general louis de joy
a trump mega donor who implemented cuts
to the postal service
at the height of the pandemic and in the
lead-up to last november's
mail-in voting detroit's latest plans
for the agency reportedly include
reducing services for local mail and
raising postage rates by nearly 10
percent
we can't do so much more for our
communities than what we do now
so if he's not willing to look outside
of
what we currently do if he just wants to
cut what we have and turn us into a
business
then he does not belong in the postal
service because you can't run this
service
with that close-minded attitude everyone
agrees the u.s postal service cannot
continue on its current footing
but the visions for how to help the
agency defer even as most believe
the service is worth saving heidi joe
castro al jazeera washington